- [Instructor] In previous videos
how Rome became a Republic in 509 BCE,
but it's worth noting, and
I've done this in other videos,
that at that point Rome
was not this vast empire.
It was really just in
control of Rome itself.
But over the next few hundred
years, it starts to expand.
Rome is a militaristic society.
The Roman legions start
to exert it's influence
over more and more of
the surrounding people
on the Italian Peninsula.
We keep going several hundred years
until we enter into the 3rd century BCE.
This is a map of what the
Mediterranean, at least,
looks like roughly as we enter
into that 3rd century BCE.
You see, even though that Rome
has now exerted it's power
over most of the Italian
Peninsula right over here,
it was not the dominant
power in the Mediterranean.
It was really the upstart,
the new and growing empire.
There are other significant empires.
You see here the remnants of
Alexander the Great's empire,
his successors each now with
their own significant empire,
and in particular, Ptolemaic
Egypt and Seleucid Persia,
which had control over
much of the Middle East.
The other empire that you see here in blue
was the Carthaginian Empire.
As we will see in the 3rd
and 2nd centuries BCE,
Rome and Carthage are going
to come at loggerheads,
and Rome, eventually,
is going to overthrow
Carthage as the dominant
empire in the Mediterranean.
But you can see in this
map right over here,
entering into the 3rd century BCE,
Carthage, that you see in blue,
was a significant empire.
So the question is, who
were these Carthaginians?
The answer is is that
they were Phoenicians.
Another answer is, even the
Phoenicians did not call
themselves Phoenicians,
but to understand where
all of this came from,
we have to go back 5,000 years ago.
5,000 years before, roughly
5,000 years before now,
around 3,000 BCE, where you have
these city-states like Tyre and Sidon.
I don't know if you can see those well.
Let me rewrite it.
That is Tyre, this is Sidon.
Now, this map is obviously a
map of the 3rd century BCE,
but if you go back to when
these cities were founded,
in fact, before they
were, I guess you can say,
put under the influence of Nebuchadnezzar
and then accumulated Persia,
these were independent city-states.
They're actually existing
cities in modern day Lebanon.
In this region, then,
the leading cities were Tyre and Sidon.
You had a group of people that
would later be known as the Phoenicians.
The Phoenicians were
famous for many things.
They were famous as traders,
as really ship builders, and traders.
And they colonized much of,
or large segments, of the
coastline of the Mediterranean.
This is going back thousands
and thousands of years.
Carthage was one of those colonies.
It was established in the 9th century,
this is what modern
day historians believe,
sometime between 846 and 813 BCE.
It was a Phoenician
colony, it was set up as,
really, a trading post for
the Tyrians, right over here.
The reason why they're called Phoenicians,
they didn't call themselves Phoenicians,
these Phoenician people,
they were called that
by the Greeks and later the Romans,
because they were famous for
trading their purple dye.
They had their purple dye,
which was derived from mollusk mucous
that they were able to get from the sea,
as great sea traders and ship builders.
They had this purple dye, and
the term for this purple dye,
it was related to the word
phoinikes, or pho-ni-cian,
and I know I'm not pronouncing it well.
The Greeks and the Romans
of the time called them
the Phoenician people
for their purple dye.
Now, Carthage, as we will see
in probably the next video,
Carthage has a series of wars with Rome,
which are called the Punic Wars.
I've always wondered, where
does that term Punic come from?
Why isn't it called the Carthaginian Wars,
or the Roman-Carthaginian Wars?
And that's because the Carthaginians
were referred to their origins
as coming from Phoenicia.
The Latin term for that was poenicus,
once again, related to the
Greek word for that purple dye.
So poenicus became punic,
so the idea of Phoenician,
these are all related words to each other.
When we're talking about the Punic Wars,
these are the Romans,
or this is the modern day English.
The Romans would have said poenicus.
These wars were referring
to the wars with Carthage,
who were descendant from the Phoenicians.
Now, just as a side note,
another thing that you
might be wondering about is,
hey, this word, Phoenician,
it looks familiar.
It looks like phonetic,
like the phonetic alphabet.
That was the other famous
contribution of the Phoenicians,
is that our alphabet,
the idea of our alphabet,
was derived from the Phoenetic
alphabet of the Phoenicians.
The Phoenicians did
many, many, many things.
They settled much, they were
one of the real naval powers
of the Mediterranean going back
thousands, and thousands of years.
By the time we get to the
Middle Roman Republic,
we're in the 3rd century
BCE, we're in the 200s BCE,
the ancient cities of Tyre and Sidon,
they're now part of the Seleucid Empire.
The Seleucid Empire was one of
the successor empires
of Alexander the Great,
but their offspring,
so to speak, Carthage,
is now a dominant power
in the Mediterranean.
With Rome starting to exert it's might,
although it has very powerful armies,
it does not, at this point,
have a very powerful navy.
But as we will see, as we get to 264 BCE,
these two great powers
in the Mediterranean
start to come into a
little bit of conflict.